Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. On today's episode, we are talking with Thomas, who is an incoming trainee clinical
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将与即将成为临床心理学实习生的Thomas进行交流。
psychologist. We are talking about so many interesting things, namely being a slightly older applicant and also starting studying later in life as well, following revelations in a personal life that made existential ponderings happen it's a fascinating listen i hope you'll find it so useful and also stay tuned right to the end for thomas's top tips on how to reduce burnout along the way to becoming whatever psychologist you aim to be if you're looking to become a psychologist whatever psychologist you pleasure to be bringing this podcast to you since December 2021. And I have no plans to stop. So if you have any ideas for content you'd love to hear about, please do let me know.
我们讨论了许多有趣的话题，特别是作为一名年龄稍大的申请者，以及在人生后期开始学习的经历。在个人生活发生了一些让他产生存在主义思考的变故之后，这段经历非常引人入胜。我希望你会觉得它很有用。另外，请务必听到最后，获取Thomas关于在成为心理学家的道路上如何减少职业倦怠的建议。如果你正打算成为一名心理学家，无论你想成为哪种心理学家，自2021年12月以来，能为大家带来这档播客我感到非常荣幸，而且我没有停止的打算。所以，如果你有任何想听的内容建议，请务必告诉我。
Guest for today's episode did get in contact with me via LinkedIn. And I have to say the first time I didn't see the message, but he responded again in a message to something he'd heard me say in the podcast as a call out for if people had ideas. And that was about the age of you compared to your supervisor and how the dynamics play out and that is absolutely something that's cropping up in today's episode and it's really fascinating stuff it's a really useful listen or watch if you're watching on youtube if you are watching on youtube please do take a moment to like, to subscribe, to put a comment in and to share the content.
今天的嘉宾是通过LinkedIn与我取得联系的。我必须承认，第一次我没看到他的消息，但他后来针对我在播客中提到的一个话题再次回复了我，当时我正在征集大家的想法。那个话题是关于你与主管之间的年龄差异以及互动动态，这绝对是今天节目中会出现的内容，非常引人入胜。如果你是在YouTube上观看，这会是一次非常有用的收听或观看体验。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请花点时间点赞、订阅、评论并分享这些内容。
If you think I think it's useful and other people might benefit, too. Please do also come along and discuss this episode in my free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. If you are listening on Spotify or Apple, please do take a moment to rate and review. It really does mean so much. So with no further ado, let's plow on with this episode and I will catch you on the other side. So I just want to welcome along Thomas, an incoming trainee clinical psychologist to the podcast. Hi, Thomas. Hi, Marianne. clinical psychologist to the podcast. Hi Thomas. Hi Marianne, thank you for having me. Oh well thank you for reaching out and I'm sorry that I did miss your first LinkedIn message but persistence definitely pays off. I am nothing
如果你觉得这很有用，其他人也可能从中受益，请务必加入我的免费Facebook群组“Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent”来讨论这一集。如果你是在Spotify或Apple上收听，也请花点时间评分和评论。这对我意义重大。那么，废话不多说，让我们继续这一集，稍后见。我想欢迎即将成为临床心理学实习生的Thomas来到播客。你好，Thomas。你好，Marianne，谢谢你邀请我。哦，谢谢你主动联系我，很抱歉我错过了你第一条LinkedIn消息，但坚持确实会有回报。我没什么
if not persistent that's for sure. I love that. So we're gonna hear about a variety of different reasons why I think that you make a great podcast guest and why our audience are going to really love what you've got to say. For anybody watching on YouTube, you might well have noticed that Thomas is my age. And we've also coordinated our outfits beautifully. We've gone for the same shade of burned orange um so yeah you are 42 is that right Thomas yes I am yeah fellow 81 baby maybe but um yeah how is 40 how's 42 working um so far it's been pretty great um I think uh my 40s have so far been my best decade um and I think the way it's shaping up it's going to continue to go that way so yeah I think 40s pretty great I'm quite glad to be here in my 40s I know I feel similarly and yet it was
如果不是坚持的话，那肯定就是坚持。我喜欢这一点。所以我们将会听到各种各样的原因，为什么我认为你会成为一名出色的播客嘉宾，以及为什么我们的听众会非常喜欢你的分享。对于在YouTube上观看的朋友，你们可能已经注意到Thomas和我同龄。而且我们还非常默契地搭配了服装。我们都选择了同样的焦橙色，所以，你今年42岁，对吧，Thomas？是的，没错，81年的同龄人。那么，42岁感觉如何？到目前为止感觉很棒，我觉得我的40多岁是我人生中最好的十年，而且从目前的发展来看，它会继续保持下去，所以我很高兴能进入40多岁。我知道，我有同感，但曾经
something I was dreading I know it's something I spoke about on the podcast recently but I really thought it was going to all be downhill and quite depressing and I'd feel awful and old and like my life was over yeah I think I think in my 20s I think well I don't even think I even thought about getting to 40 or what that would look like but I think I think it was probably like quite grey like visually in my mind I think it was all in black and white and it was all quite boring and somber um but it isn't it's burnt orange instead I was just thinking 40 is burnt orange color you know so was it lavender and lilac is 70s and 80s but clearly 40s is burnt orange but I think it didn't help me that when I was 39 just before the world ground to a halt with a pandemic my eyes packed up and
那是我一直担心的事情。我知道我最近在播客中提到过，我真的以为一切都会走下坡路，会很沮丧，我会感觉糟糕、衰老，觉得人生结束了。是的，我想我在20多岁的时候，甚至没想过要到40岁，或者那会是什么样子。但在我的脑海里，它可能看起来很灰暗，就像黑白电影一样，非常无聊和沉闷。但事实并非如此，它是焦橙色的。我刚才就在想，40岁是焦橙色的，你知道吗？薰衣草色和淡紫色是70岁和80岁的颜色，但显然40岁是焦橙色。但对我来说，39岁时，就在世界因疫情停摆之前，我的视力变差了，这并没有什么帮助。
I suddenly needed glasses and I was like oh god this is so depressing this is just what my 40s is going to be there's going to be one ailment after another yeah since leaving university which maybe we'll come on to because I only recently left university um yeah I got in I got into my job and I started to get headaches and migraines so hence hence I also now wear glasses and the yeah the person who did my eye test she did say well it's just a sign of aging I was like oh terrific here it comes it's already here absolutely it comes it's here absolutely I've also got a very similar pair of glasses to you as well so we could be like twins burnt orange black frame glasses yeah so it's burnt orange and kind of roundish glasses as well it's where it's at it's
我突然需要戴眼镜了，当时我想，天哪，这太令人沮丧了，我的40多岁就是这样吗？会是一个接一个的病痛。是的，自从离开大学后——也许我们稍后会谈到，因为我最近才离开大学——我开始工作，然后就开始头痛和偏头痛，所以我也开始戴眼镜了。给我做视力检查的人确实说，这只是衰老的迹象。我说，哦，太棒了，它来了，它已经在这里了。绝对是，它来了，它就在这里。我也有一副和你非常相似的眼镜，所以我们就像双胞胎一样，焦橙色，黑框眼镜。是的，所以它是焦橙色，而且镜框也是圆圆的，这就是潮流所在。
where all the cool kids hang out I think yeah so yeah you mentioned there that you went to university a little later than probably the average listener um would have done could you guide us through your steps a little bit if that's okay yeah um so definitely older than um the kind of typical um so I never went to university at the at the kind of typical age um partly because I never finished my A-levels so whoops um I tried tried twice um and didn't get to the end either time um so I wasn't qualified to go to university but I also wasn't uh I don't know just personally emotionally developmentally qualified to take that either um so instead I just spent um a decade and a half moving from job to job completely disparate squiggle of a of a path um So I was, yeah, that was maybe 15 years. I guess I had a significant life event in my mid-30s,
这是所有酷孩子聚集的地方。是的，你刚才提到你比一般的听众更晚一点上大学，能带我们了解一下你的经历吗？好的，当然。是的，我确实比典型的学生年龄要大。我从来没有在典型的年龄上过大学，部分原因是我从来没有完成我的A-level考试，哎呀。我尝试了两次，但两次都没有坚持到最后，所以我没有资格上大学。而且我也觉得，无论是个人、情感还是发展上，我都没有准备好去接受那个。所以，我花了十五年的时间在不同的工作之间跳槽，走了一条完全支离破碎的道路。所以，是的，那大概是15年。我想我在30多岁中期经历了一次重大的人生事件，
the kind of life event that makes you very quickly and clearly reassess what it is that you're doing, why you're doing it. And it kind of distills all of the the nonsense that you tell yourself so that's what happened to me and I very quickly decided that enough was enough of not doing anything without a great deal of purpose or direction and to actually do the thing that secretly was the thing that I always wanted to do and the thing that I would always like to develop as, which is to be some kind of psychologist. So, yeah, so I went part time in my job.
那种让你非常迅速且清晰地重新评估你正在做什么、为什么做这件事的人生事件。它过滤掉了你对自己说的所有废话，这就是发生在我身上的事情。我很快决定，不能再这样毫无目的或方向地做任何事情了，我要去做那件我一直秘密想做的事情，那件我一直想发展的事情，那就是成为某种心理学家。所以，是的，我把工作改成了兼职。
Not having any A-levels was a bit of a barrier, still a barrier to university so I did a an access to higher education course which is a kind of part time part-ish time one year course which is equivalent to two a levels and I did that in psychology sociology and social policy and then from that I got into my undergrad and that was in 2018. So I graduated 2021. So, yeah, not not the typical timeline. Definitely not. But actually, you've encompassed a whole pandemic there as well. So you were you were studying your undergrad during that time. Yeah, it was epiphany term second year, wasn't it? So that's basically half of the degree and half of the experience of being at university was then kind of taken away from us.
没有A-level证书确实是一个障碍，仍然是上大学的障碍，所以我参加了一个高等教育入学课程，这是一个为期一年的兼职课程，相当于两个A-level，我学习了心理学、社会学和社会政策。然后从那里我进入了本科，那是2018年。所以我2021年毕业。所以，是的，不是典型的时间线。绝对不是。但实际上，你还经历了一整场疫情。所以你在那段时间里完成了你的本科学习。是的，那是第二年的顿悟期，不是吗？所以基本上，一半的学位和一半的大学体验就这样被剥夺了。
I think part of me actually still mourns the death of that third year in terms of the experience of it. I know everyone will have their own version of this but i think for for me and and maybe other people in my cohort um that's that was our experience of having that taken away um which yeah i i still wish it there are things left undone things left unsaidaid that always will be, which is a shame. But like I said, everyone has their own version of that in some way. Absolutely. I wrote some stuff for the media about grief linked to the pandemic that was not to do with death and dying. And there's so many things that so many of us missed out on.
我想我内心的一部分实际上还在哀悼那第三年的逝去，就体验而言。我知道每个人对此都有自己的看法，但对我以及我那一届的其他同学来说，这就是我们被剥夺的体验。这确实……我仍然希望它还在，有些事情没有完成，有些话没有说出口，这永远都会是遗憾。但就像我说的，每个人在某种程度上都有自己的版本。绝对是。我曾为媒体写过一些关于与疫情相关的悲伤的文章，那与死亡无关。我们很多人错过了太多的事情。
And like you said, that can't be undone. You can't get a do over, a redo on them. And it's okay to be sad and to grieve for something, even though you might not have lost somebody, you know, through death in the pandemic. It's okay to grieve for important life events that didn't get to happen as they would have done otherwise. Yeah, absolutely absolutely I agree um I think there's a lot to be said for the the death of a fantasy a projected death and that plays out in it plays out in my role as well my current role um that I see what people imagine their future and their life is going to be, um,
就像你说的，那无法挽回。你无法重来，无法重做。感到难过并为某事哀悼是可以的，即使你可能没有在疫情中失去亲人。为那些本可以发生但最终没有发生的重要人生事件感到悲伤是可以的。是的，绝对，绝对，我同意。我认为对于幻想的破灭有很多话要说，这在我的角色中也有体现，我目前的工作中，我看到人们想象他们的未来和生活会是什么样子，
doesn't happen. And there's a, there's a, there is, yeah, there is a, there is a struggle, um,
结果却并没有发生。而且，有一种挣扎，
in moving from the fantasy to, to reality and, and reconciling that those, those two things are never going to be the same. Um, yeah. So there was a small version of that for me not not comparable but a version my own version yeah absolutely and I feel like I want to ask you a thousand other questions about other things
在从幻想走向现实的过程中，并调和这两者永远不会是一回事的事实。是的。所以对我来说有一个小版本，虽然无法相比，但确实是我自己的版本。是的，绝对。我觉得我想问你关于你提到的其他事情的成千上万个问题，
you've mentioned but what I want to do before we move on is to just say gosh well done like you know you make it sound quite easy that you dropped down to part time and did a whole degree during the whole pandemic whilst working and, you know, running your own life in the background as well. But, you know, there's clearly something that really resonated with you that made you accountable to yourself and gave you permission to take yourself seriously and to do what it was you wanted and I think that's incredible and you know just hats off to you for treating yourself with respect and thinking about what you want the next 40 years to look like rather than just thinking you know it's the sunk cost fallacy isn't it I don't know if you've heard that term before but you think well oh you know I've already had 35 years of this and it's been all right. I'll just carry on as I am. But you were like, no, actually, by the time I get to the next 35, 40 years,
但在我们继续之前，我只想说，天哪，做得好。你知道，你让这一切听起来很容易，你转为兼职，在整个疫情期间完成了一个完整的学位，同时还在工作，在后台经营着自己的生活。但是，显然有一些东西真正引起了你的共鸣，让你对自己负责，并给了你许可去认真对待自己，去做你想做的事情。我觉得这太不可思议了，向你致敬，因为你尊重自己，思考未来40年想要什么，而不是仅仅考虑沉没成本谬误。我不知道你以前是否听过这个词，但你会想，哦，你知道，我已经这样过了35年，而且一直都还行，我就这样继续下去吧。但你却说，不，实际上，当我到达下一个35、40年时，
I'd like to think that there's been a different chunk of my life. Yeah, I love that reflection. And that's absolutely the process that happened. As I said, with this kind of significant life event, it happened in a very, very short space of time, just within just a few weeks. And in terms of the sunk cost fallacy, absolutely. things that I left behind was playing music and songwriting which I'd been kind of living a parallel life alongside my kind of day jobs that I didn't really care about or wasn't really developing in almost kind of intentionally because I was trying to become a professional songwriter and I spent a long time doing that and developing it. And it was part of my identity. I was really committed, or I thought I was. I thought I enjoyed it.
我希望我的人生能有不同的一面。是的，我喜欢这个反思。这绝对是发生的过程。正如我所说，随着这种重大的人生事件，它在非常非常短的时间内发生，就在几周之内。关于沉没成本谬误，绝对是。我留下的东西之一是演奏音乐和写歌，我一直过着一种平行生活，伴随着我并不真正关心或没有真正发展的日常工作，几乎是刻意的，因为我试图成为一名专业词曲作者，我花了很多时间做这件事并发展它。这是我身份的一部分。我真的很投入，或者我以为我很投入。我以为我喜欢它。
I thought it was good for me. And just within a few weeks, all of that, I dropped it all. I dropped the whole thing from who I was and what I was doing. And yeah, so in the sunk cost fallacy, it was this really clear period of time where everything became kind of HD. And it was like, none of this is really worth anything to me or maybe even to anybody else. Not in a wider sense of things. And it's, yeah, what you said about accountability is absolutely one of the first thoughts, one of the foundational thoughts that I had was just really simply at some point I'm going to die and it's going to be sooner than I think.
我以为它对我很好。但在几周之内，所有这些，我全部放弃了。我从我是谁以及我在做什么中放弃了这一切。所以，在沉没成本谬误中，那是一段非常清晰的时间，一切都变得高清了。就像，这一切对我来说真的没有任何价值，甚至对其他人来说可能也是。不是在更广泛的意义上。而且，你关于责任所说的话，绝对是我最初的想法之一，我拥有的基础想法之一，仅仅是简单地，在某个时候我会死，而且会比我想象的要早。
And I had better have more to show for it than what I have right now. And what I have right now isn't enough. And if today was the last day, I would be really disappointed with myself so yeah really insightful reflection in terms of the accountability and that's that's what it is really and part of that process was actually leaving myself to be accountable only to myself. Yeah absolutely it's powerful stuff thank you for sharing that with us and as you speak I'm remembering my dad who died when he was 71 much sooner than we would have liked but you know his deathbed regrets and they're always quite interesting to think about what what people think about on the deathbed and his was you know I wish I'd worked harder in school but
我最好能比现在有更多的成就。而我现在拥有的还不够。如果今天是最后一天，我会对自己非常失望。所以，是的，在责任方面非常有见地的反思，这就是它的本质。而这个过程的一部分实际上是让我自己只对自己负责。是的，绝对，这是强大的东西，谢谢你与我们分享。当你说话时，我想起了我父亲，他在71岁时去世了，比我们希望的要早得多，但你知道，他在临终前的遗憾，思考人们在临终时会想什么总是很有趣，他的遗憾是，我希望我在学校时更努力一些，但
yours will now not be that because you've had that sort of epiphany moment that you have been able to think about doing things differently you know and you know that's really powerful stuff yeah I mean it's been powerful enough to make me change everything that I was doing, basically, to become completely unrecognisable in the space of five years from what it was. So, yeah, and it continues to be the driver and continues to help, I suppose. Also, like you said about looking ahead for the next 40 years. Yeah, that is something that I think about and think to construct. And maybe I'm building a fantasy that I have to adjust and reconcile with not achieving. But I have those things laid out now. Whereas before I didn't, not really.
你的现在不会是那样，因为你有了那种顿悟时刻，你能够思考以不同的方式做事。你知道，这真的很强大。是的，我的意思是，它足够强大，让我改变了我正在做的一切，基本上，在五年内变得完全无法辨认。所以，是的，它继续成为驱动力，并继续提供帮助，我想。还有，就像你说的关于展望未来40年。是的，这是我思考和构建的事情。也许我正在构建一个我必须调整并调和无法实现的幻想。但我现在已经把这些事情列出来了。而以前我没有，真的没有。
It's quite vague. I'm kind of thinking about trauma and recovery. So trauma is my specialty and I'm thinking about it being about seven years, actually, since you started this kind of moment of growth and change. And it's said that in seven years, all of our cells will renew. And so, you know, even the cells on your arm are actually different than they were seven years ago. And that can be a helpful thing for people to grapple with when they've been, for example, assaulted or hurt. It's like actually the body now that you have is now different than the body that was hurt by that person. And that can be really helpful.
这很模糊。我正在思考创伤和恢复。所以创伤是我的专长，我想到实际上距离你开始这种成长和改变的时刻已经大约七年了。据说在七年内，我们所有的细胞都会更新。所以，你知道，即使你手臂上的细胞实际上也与七年前不同了。当人们例如受到攻击或伤害时，这对于人们去应对可能是一件有帮助的事情。就像，实际上你现在拥有的身体与被那个人伤害时的身体不同了。这真的很有帮助。
But in thinking about recovery, mental health recovery, I think you've done something really incredible and something that's going to be a real gift to people that might hear this podcast episode even in years to come, that they might be in a position now that feels like they're feeling quite stuck, quite trapped. So think what you've done there really beautifully is you've given hope to so many people who might be struggling at the moment, who might be struggling to imagine that their life could ever be different, that they could be working in a career that they enjoy, that they could be working in a career that they enjoy, that they could be looking forward to the next decades of their life, not just scraping by,
但在思考恢复，心理健康恢复时，我认为你做了一些非常不可思议的事情，这将是给那些即使在多年后听到这期播客的人的一份真正的礼物，他们现在可能处于一种感觉非常卡住、非常被困住的位置。所以我想你做得非常漂亮的是，你给了许多目前可能正在挣扎的人希望，他们可能正在努力想象他们的生活可能会有所不同，他们可能会从事一份他们喜欢的工作，他们可能会从事一份他们喜欢的工作，他们可能会期待未来几十年的生活，而不仅仅是勉强维持，
that they can potentially enter a realm of pay and rewards that are going to be, you know, offering them and their family financial security, not just now, but in terms of pension as well. And I think, wow, what a gift for people to think how much they could turn their lives around. And, you know, you've done it. I think that's just incredible. Again, hats off to you. Thanks.
他们有可能进入一个薪酬和回报的领域，这将为他们和他们的家人提供经济保障，不仅是现在，而且在养老金方面也是如此。我认为，哇，人们能想到他们能多大程度地扭转自己的生活，这是一份多么好的礼物。而且，你知道，你做到了。我认为这太不可思议了。再次向你致敬。谢谢。
I haven't really thought about it in that way. I'll leave that for you to say. Things like that don't really sit very comfortably with me, the idea that I might inspire somebody you mentioned that I'd not heard of was a colourful leadership test. We've obviously both burnt orange, but could you tell us a little bit about that for people that might be listening? Oh, so in the service I work in, we have two trainees. we always have two second year trainees so um occasionally i get to kind of dip into um some of their teaching and uh we were talking about it was part of their their leadership um training uh they were looking at um four different personality types and that these personality sites were kind of color-coded um i must preface this by saying i don't i don't know if this is like an evidence-based thing or not um but it was really cool regardless
我并没有真正那样想过。我会留给你去说。像那样的事情对我来说并不太舒服，我可能会激励某人的想法。你提到了一个我没听说过的彩色领导力测试。我们显然都穿了焦橙色，但你能为可能正在收听的人介绍一下吗？哦，在我工作的服务部门，我们有两名实习生。我们总是有两名二年级实习生，所以偶尔我会参与他们的一些教学。我们当时在谈论，这是他们领导力培训的一部分，他们正在研究四种不同的性格类型，这些性格类型是用颜色编码的。我必须先说明，我不知道这是否是有证据支持的，但无论如何它真的很酷。
and um the idea the exercise was that there was a whole bunch of words um put on the screen and you have to um really quickly without trying to think about it too much, write down the words that you think really relate to you, really vibe with you. So you do that really quickly. And then on the next screen, all those words are then colour coded. So then you count up how many greens you have, how many reds you have, how many blues and how many yellows the idea is that um whichever color you have the most of that's your dominant kind of personality type uh so mine was green uh which apparently most of their cohort was so i guess i'm maybe i'm doing something right um in choosing this pathway um so green green was all about kind of so what one of one of the one of the things that it then splits is, so a green person, a green personality, this is so squidgy, isn't it?
这个练习的想法是，屏幕上有一堆词，你必须非常快地，在不加太多思考的情况下，写下你认为真正与你相关、真正与你产生共鸣的词。所以你很快地做完。然后在下一个屏幕上，所有这些词都被颜色编码了。然后你数数你有多少个绿色，多少个红色，多少个蓝色，多少个黄色。想法是，无论哪种颜色你最多，那就是你的主导性格类型。所以我是绿色，显然他们那一届大多数人都是绿色，所以我猜我选择这条道路可能做对了什么。所以绿色，绿色是关于……所以它划分的一件事是，一个绿色的人，一种绿色性格，这太模糊了，不是吗？
So fluffy, but the green personality on a good day, this is what they look like. So they look like they're compassionate, they're kind, they're patient. It's like, okay, that sounds like someone who could do do well as a psychologist and then it says on a bad day this is what they would look like and and one of the I mean this was basically my take-home message that on a bad day I'm bland it actually said bland so I was like okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna go on a podcast and I I really need to make sure that I that people catch me on a good day. Otherwise, this is going to be an awful podcast. I was muted, so you couldn't hear me laughing.
太虚了，但绿色性格在好的一天，这就是他们的样子。他们看起来富有同情心，善良，耐心。就像，好吧，这听起来像是一个能成为优秀心理学家的人。然后它说在糟糕的一天，这就是他们的样子。我的意思是，这是我的主要收获，在糟糕的一天，我是平淡的。它实际上说的是平淡。所以我当时想，好吧，我要去参加一个播客，我真的需要确保人们在好的一天遇到我。否则，这将是一个糟糕的播客。我当时静音了，所以你听不到我在笑。
But I love that. I love that. And my kids tell me that of all of their YouTubers that they're a fan of, I am their least favorite. Which is just delightful. Yeah, they say I should be doing videos on Minecraft because they'd be much more popular. Obviously, yeah, of course.
但我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。我的孩子们告诉我，在他们喜欢的YouTube博主中，我是他们最不喜欢的一个。这真是太令人愉快了。是的，他们说我应该做关于Minecraft的视频，因为那样会更受欢迎。显然，是的，当然。
That's what the world needs more of. I think there's a lot of value in the bland as well. I really do. Really? Okay. Not that I'm condoning that you're bland, but what am I like on a bad day so I guess I would question the bad day aspect of it so I'm a whole person you are a whole person and there will be aspects of me some of which will be more sociable some of which will be chattier some of which will be more sociable, some of which will be chattier, some of which need to be
这就是世界需要更多的东西。我认为平淡中也有很多价值。我真的这么认为。真的吗？好吧。并不是说我纵容你是平淡的，但我在糟糕的一天是什么样的？所以我猜我会质疑它的糟糕一天方面。所以我是一个完整的人，你是一个完整的人，我会有一些方面，其中一些会更善于交际，其中一些会更健谈，其中一些会更善于交际，其中一些会更健谈，其中一些需要
left alone and like to be, you know, like to spend time by myself. And it's me as a holistic person. So if you catch me on a day where I don't want to chat, then if I see you in the supermarket, then I probably will hide because I'm just not in that mood you know um and sometimes if I've done something really really social for days and days on end I just want to spend a day in bed reading my book but that's not necessarily a bad day that's about nourishing and respecting myself um but yeah you, I guess some of the stuff I talk about is bland, is boring, unless that topic really resonates with you. And over 42,000 people resonated with the topics I've discussed so far. So it can't be super bland. And I think
被单独留下，喜欢独自一人。这是作为一个整体的我。所以如果你在我不愿聊天的那天遇到我，如果我在超市看到你，我可能会躲起来，因为我根本没有那种心情。你知道，有时如果我连续几天做了非常非常社交的事情，我只想在床上待一天看书，但这并不一定意味着那是糟糕的一天，那是关于滋养和尊重我自己。但是的，你，我猜我谈论的一些东西是平淡的，是无聊的，除非那个话题真的引起你的共鸣。到目前为止，超过42,000人对我说过的话题产生了共鸣。所以它不可能超级平淡。而且我认为
life is not always a roller coaster adventure, is it? You know, you and I have had 42 years of it. Some, you know, every day at bedtime, my children and I do. So I've got a nine year old who will like me to tell you he's almost 10 and a seven year old. And every day at bedtime, I'm by no means a perfect parent if people are thinking oh gosh she's amazing because I'm not um every day at bedtime with both of them we do a what's the favorite part of your day and what's the least favorite part of the day but they also ask me the same question and you know I get loads of lovely things from them about their favourite and their least favourite. And sometimes my most favourite day is replies just like, it was just all right.
生活并不总是一场过山车冒险，不是吗？你知道，你和我已经经历了42年。有些，你知道，每天睡觉前，我和我的孩子们都会做。我有一个9岁的孩子，他会希望我告诉你他快10岁了，还有一个7岁的孩子。每天睡觉前，我绝不是一个完美的父母，如果人们在想，哦天哪，她太棒了，因为我不是。每天睡觉前，我们都会和他们两个一起做“你今天最喜欢的部分是什么，最不喜欢的部分是什么”。但他们也会问我同样的问题，你知道，我从他们那里得到了很多关于他们最喜欢和最不喜欢的事情的可爱回答。有时我最喜欢的一天回复只是，它只是还行。
There wasn't anything particularly good. There wasn't anything particularly bad. It was just a day. And isn't that just adulting, really? Sometimes it's a bit vanilla. sometimes it is a bit bland yeah yeah definitely yeah definitely um I was also thinking about I mean I mean yeah I mean there's a lot of plateauing that goes on in life isn't there um between the the bumps and and the troughs um but i i actually like when when you said oh maybe it's a good thing i did actually think well maybe in terms of like um the idea of the the blank canvas therapist um being able to you know kind of absorb transference um
没有什么特别好的。没有什么特别坏的。它只是平凡的一天。这不就是成年人的生活吗？有时它有点香草味。有时它确实有点平淡。是的，是的，绝对，是的，绝对。我还在想，我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，生活中有很多平台期，不是吗？在起伏和低谷之间。但我实际上喜欢当你说是啊，也许这是一件好事时，我确实想，也许就……那种空白画布治疗师的想法，能够吸收移情，
there's maybe something in that. Maybe another way of looking at it would be that. So maybe I should be channeling my inner bland during sessions and then I can pick up all this transference. So, yeah, maybe it's my secret power, my blandness, but maybe just not as a podcast guest. I really don't think you are bland but I think what's really brilliant about training and what you might well experience for yourself too
也许其中有一些东西。也许另一种看待它的方式会是那样。所以也许我应该在治疗过程中引导我内心的平淡，然后我就可以吸收所有这些移情。所以，是的，也许这是我的秘密力量，我的平淡，但也许只是不作为播客嘉宾。我真的不认为你是平淡的，但我认为关于培训，以及你可能也会亲身体验到的非常棒的事情是
is that you're likely to do a variety of different approaches during training so in my first year I was really into psychodynamic and that sort of I'd started to pave the way for psychodynamic placement for placement six but my latter interests were much more probably humanistic and I've ended up doing CFT so if I'd been introduced to CFT for anyone listening it's not sure what that is that's compassion focused therapy earlier in the process I might well have done something different but what I really like about training is you get a chance to try on different hats. So I did solution focused. I did systemic. I did psychodynamic. And you get to see, oh, well, what happens when I when I run therapy sessions in this way?
你很可能会在培训期间尝试各种不同的方法。在第一年，我非常喜欢心理动力学，那种……我已经开始为第六次实习的心理动力学实习铺平道路，但我后来的兴趣更多是人本主义的，我最终做了CFT。所以如果我早点在过程中被介绍给CFT——对于任何听众来说，如果不确定那是什么，那是同情聚焦疗法——我可能已经做了不同的事情。但我真正喜欢培训的是，你有机会尝试不同的帽子。所以我做了以解决方案为中心的。我做了系统性的。我做了心理动力学。你可以看到，哦，好吧，当我以这种方式进行治疗时会发生什么？
And then you get to think about which bits you like, which bits you want to keep, and which bits you want to leave there and never use again. And so, you know, I would empower you to try and really get, I mean, some of it's not within your control, but to try and get as wide a variety of exposure to different therapeutic orientations on placements as you can and that might even be when you're on placement seeking out maybe someone that's not your supervisor to shadow some sessions with and to maybe have some ad hoc supervision sessions with to get a different understanding of what is likely to be a very similar population within your service because I've learned so much from people in that way. Yeah, I absolutely agree with that, especially considering trainees are trainees.
然后你可以思考你喜欢哪些部分，你想保留哪些部分，以及你想把哪些部分留在那里再也不用。所以，你知道，我会授权你去尝试并真正获得——我的意思是，其中一些不在你的控制范围内——但要尝试在实习中获得尽可能广泛的治疗取向接触，这甚至可能是在实习期间，寻找可能不是你的主管的人去旁听一些课程，并进行一些临时督导课程，以获得对你服务中可能非常相似的人群的不同理解，因为我通过这种方式从人们那里学到了很多。是的，我绝对同意这一点，特别是考虑到实习生就是实习生。
They are being developed from one side to the other. And when they qualify, they're at the beginning of their career as a clinical psychologist um it's not the the doctorate isn't isn't the end goal it's it's um the preface of the beginning um and if you want to put it like that so the idea of being trained in as broad a way as possible is something that really appeals to me it really appeals appeals to me about the course that I'm joining. It's one of the reasons why I applied for it is that they offer training in four different models. I'm not quite sure how I feel about CBT plus one on a lot of the courses, given that trainees are not even qualified yet and why you would narrow it down at such an early stage in people's careers
他们正在从一边被发展到另一边。当他们获得资格时，他们处于临床心理学家职业生涯的开始。这不是博士学位不是最终目标，它是开始的序言，如果你想这样说的话。所以以尽可能广泛的方式接受培训的想法是我非常感兴趣的。它非常吸引我，关于我正在加入的课程。这是我申请它的原因之一，他们提供四种不同模型的培训。我不确定我对很多课程上的CBT加一有什么感觉，考虑到实习生甚至还没有获得资格，为什么你会把范围缩小到人们职业生涯的早期阶段
um not notwithstanding the fact that you can you can then qualify and you have a whole career in which to explore different things but um personally i think the course is maybe the perfect time um to explore those things and i'm i've been really lucky in the service that I work in that I've been able to experience and use adapted versions of different models, which has been, yeah, has been terrifically privileged and fortunate that I've had that kind of AP role. So, for example, for one client, we used CBT for the formulation stage, but then used CFT for the kind of intervention stage. So we kind of, not strictly, but adapted versions of both things, but we kind of just brought in elements from CFT. And I really like that sort of integration of different ideas and different models.
尽管你可以获得资格，并且你有整个职业生涯去探索不同的事情，但个人认为，课程也许是探索这些事情的完美时间。而且我在我工作的服务部门非常幸运，我能够体验和使用不同模型的改编版本，这真是非常荣幸和幸运，我有那种AP角色。所以，例如，对于一位客户，我们在制定阶段使用了CBT，但在干预阶段使用了CFT。所以我们有点——不是严格地——但改编了这两个东西的版本，但我们引入了CFT的元素。我真的很喜欢那种不同想法和不同模型的整合。
Maybe that's how I'd like to develop, but we'll see. Again, in that seven-year cycle, I'll probably be completely different to how I am now. So, but yeah, I'm looking forward to exploring that that broad range um and especially given that you know when we think about the therapeutic alliance being the biggest predictor of a positive outcome doesn't exactly render the model or the choice it doesn't render the choice um irrelevant but it it does mean that you know exploring different models means that you can catch one that really sort of resonates with you
也许这就是我想发展的方式，但我们会看到的。同样，在那个七年的周期里，我可能会与现在的我完全不同。所以，但是的，我很期待探索那个广泛的范围。而且特别是考虑到你知道，当我们认为治疗联盟是积极结果的最大预测因素时，这并不完全使模型或选择变得无关紧要，但它确实意味着你知道，探索不同的模型意味着你可以抓住一个真正引起你共鸣的模型，
and you feel just is a kind of path of least resistance i can use this i know it it feels right it feels good i'm good at it um and that gives you maybe more of an opportunity to develop that therapeutic alliance and more opportunity to have positive outcomes maybe I don't know absolutely absolutely and I've become and this isn't it yeah I think let's let's go back to your earlier point you're you're worthy of praise and you're allowed to say good things about yourself and you're allowed others to say good things about you so I'm going to say something good about myself now to model that um I'm a much better clinical psychologist now than I was when I qualified as we are expected to be you know really it's kind of thinking about the first couple of years as being preceptorship and then
你觉得这是一种阻力最小的路径，我可以使用这个，我知道它，它感觉是对的，它感觉很好，我擅长它。而且这给了你更多机会去发展那种治疗联盟，更多机会获得积极的结果，也许我不知道。绝对，绝对。而且我已经成为——这不是，是的，我想让我们回到你之前的观点，你值得赞美，你被允许对自己说好话，你也允许别人对你说好话。所以我现在要对自己说点好话来示范一下。我现在是一名比我获得资格时更好的临床心理学家，正如我们被期望的那样。你知道，真的，这有点像把前几年看作是入职培训，然后
really you're fully qualified a couple of years later you know it's certainly it felt like the case for me I've become better and better as years have gone on but I would say that I'm now truly an integrative psychologist and what I really love about this stage of my career is that yeah every client has a different intervention because it's bespoke for them and if something stops working or if something resonates with them in a session I will literally go right okay and there might even be a uh um as I think about that I touch my mouth i do that i do do that um and i'll look off to the right and then i'll dig into my therapeutic toolbox it's like rummaging in an old doctor's bag and i will find something that is going to be transformative for them um that's just the best
真的，你几年后才完全合格。你知道，这对我来说确实是这样。随着岁月的流逝，我变得越来越好。但我会说我现在是一个真正的综合心理学家，我真正喜欢我职业生涯这个阶段的是，是的，每个客户都有不同的干预措施，因为它是为他们量身定制的。如果有什么停止工作，或者如果有什么在课程中引起他们的共鸣，我会直接说，好的。甚至可能有一个……当我想到这一点时，我摸了摸我的嘴，我确实那样做，我会看向右边，然后我会深入我的治疗工具箱，就像在旧医生包里翻找一样，我会找到一些对他们来说具有变革性的东西。那是世界上最好的
job in the world i love it being able Being able to pull across, sometimes it will be an idea from psychodynamic. Sometime it will be an idea from systemic. Sometimes it will be something completely random that I've made up for them that will resonate because it's got, um, you know, like an analogy. So I've used, um, recently i've used the idea of i don't know if you're a gardener thomas that's yet hit your world but um climbing plants will send out little shoots and i've used that to help somebody understand ocd and to help externalize that um to kind of think about it desperately looking for support and reassurance and you know it's not going to blow over in the wind but actually it's a bit of a
工作，我喜欢它。能够提取，有时它会是一个来自心理动力学的想法。有时它会是一个来自系统性的想法。有时它会是完全随机的，我为他们编造的，会引起共鸣，因为它有一个，你知道，像一个类比。所以我最近使用了，我不知道你是否是一个园丁，Thomas，那是否已经进入了你的世界，但攀缘植物会伸出小芽，我用它来帮助某人理解强迫症，并帮助将其外化，去思考它绝望地寻求支持和安慰，你知道，它不会被风吹倒，但实际上它有点
it's a bit of a lie you know OCD it's a whole another episode but that has been really helpful and so I'm just excited for where you're going and for this growth explosion you're going to have and you your brain is going to basically rewire itself which is also really exciting you know we think about that happening in key areas of you know adolescence a childhood growing adolescence and but when we also start a new job we'll suddenly often notice I can't sleep very well I'm fizzed up with ideas my brain is trying to process everything but it really is an exciting period of change and growth I'm I'm really excited for you to experience that and I hope that you find it to be a really positive experience
它有点谎言，你知道，强迫症，那是另一集了，但这真的很有帮助。所以我只是为你要去的地方感到兴奋，为你将要拥有的这种成长爆发感到兴奋，你的大脑基本上会重新连接自己，这也是非常令人兴奋的。你知道，我们认为这发生在青春期、童年成长的关键领域，但当我们开始一份新工作时，我们也会突然经常注意到，我睡不好，我充满了想法，我的大脑正在试图处理一切，但这确实是一个令人兴奋的变革和成长时期。我真的为你感到兴奋，希望你能体验到这一点，并希望你发现它是一次非常积极的体验。
um yeah same and does it does yeah I had a lot of thoughts when you when you're talking through all of that um I mean I suppose I'm quite committed to the idea of the continuous development the idea that I'll be a complete finished clinician at any stage isn't really isn't really in my thoughts so yeah in terms of like keeping my brain ticking over from here from here on in is is really comforting it's i really like it i've plateaued a lot in my working life um so the idea that there there may be no more plateaus is quite nice. And yeah, I'm definitely up for that. That's also part of the appeal of going into clinical psychology.
是的，我也是。当你谈论所有这些时，我有很多想法。我的意思是，我想我对持续发展的想法非常投入，那种我在任何阶段都会成为一个完整、完成的临床医生的想法并不真正在我的想法中。所以，是的，就让我的大脑从现在开始保持运转而言，这真的很令人欣慰。我真的很喜欢它。我在我的工作生活中经历了很多平台期，所以没有更多平台期的想法很好。而且，是的，我绝对愿意那样做。这也是进入临床心理学的吸引力的一部分。
And I suppose going into a science where we're kind of all at the same time, we're at the absolute limit of our understanding, but we're also already behind where we're going of all at the same time we're at the absolute limit of our understanding but we're also already behind where we're going to be and that really appeals to me I'm quite comfortable I feel quite comfortable being in that position and I suppose in my own development I'm quite comfortable knowing where I am but knowing also where I might be. When you're talking about developing after qualification, having the experience to integrate different models, I'm really looking forward to being able to do that. And I've seen it, of course, in more experienced colleagues. And, you know, I do occasionally fanboy a little bit over them.
而且我想进入一门科学，我们在某种程度上，我们都在同一时间，我们处于我们理解的绝对极限，但我们也已经落后于我们要去的地方，这真的很吸引我。我感到很舒服，我感到很舒服处于那个位置。而且我想在我自己的发展中，我很舒服知道我在哪里，但也知道我可能在哪里。当你谈论获得资格后的发展，拥有整合不同模型的经验时，我真的很期待能够做到这一点。而且我当然在更有经验的同事身上看到了这一点。而且，你知道，我偶尔会有点崇拜他们。
But I also know that if I just keep going just keep working hard I get a bit of luck and I'll get there as well eventually um so but I'm I'm quite comfortable and happy about like where I am now versus where I was and then quite excited about where I am now versus where I might be. Good. And yes, I also do like gardening as well. I have an allotment. Good to know. Oh, how lovely. Another 40s vibe, I think, is burnt orange on an allotment.
但我同时也知道，如果我继续努力工作，再有一点点运气，最终我也能达到目标。所以，我对现在的状态感到很舒适和满意，也对未来可能达到的高度感到兴奋。很好。是的，我也喜欢园艺。我有一个菜园。很高兴知道这一点。哦，太棒了。我觉得40多岁的氛围就是菜园里的焦橙色。
What's your most successful produce this year? Oh, gosh. Well, this year's been weird because July hasn't happened, basically. All the rain has been in the wrong place. The sun has been in the wrong place. The cold weather was in the wrong place. So goodness knows what it's like to be a plant. The radishes haven't fared well I believe this year not been
你今年最成功的农作物是什么？哦，天哪。今年很奇怪，因为七月基本上没怎么过。所有的雨都下错了地方。阳光也照错了地方。寒冷的天气也来得不是时候。所以天知道植物是什么感受。我想今年的萝卜长得不好，因为
enough water at key times. At the moment I think so my partner grows flowers so we have lots of flowers they're all looking good so I think maybe beetroot looks okay. um good yeah good good good veg update thank you um i i do think there is value in the plateau though and we can't keep relentlessly striving all the time um because it's exhausting and sometimes we do need to go to supervision and go, can't be bothered. I can't seem to make any shifts. I can't seem to make any changes. You know, I'm managing my work, but it is what it is. You know, I don't know. And I think you've got to be able to have that. But even in supervision sessions, sometimes I will learn so much because we should ideally always have a supervisor who's more experienced than ourselves to be able to help contain us to be able to help shape us and to help
在关键时期缺水。目前我觉得，我的伴侣种花，所以我们有很多花，它们看起来都不错，所以我觉得甜菜根看起来还可以。嗯，好的，好的，好的，蔬菜更新，谢谢。嗯，我确实认为平台期是有价值的，我们不能一直不停地奋斗，因为那太累了。有时我们需要去督导那里说，我没动力了。我似乎无法取得任何进展。我似乎无法做出任何改变。你知道，我在处理我的工作，但现状就是这样。你知道，我不知道。我认为你必须能够拥有那种状态。但即使在督导会议中，有时我也会学到很多，因为理想情况下，我们应该始终有一位比我们更有经验的督导，能够帮助包容我们，帮助塑造我们，并帮助
us grow and to help us think about being able to overcome things from a different perspective than the one that we're currently feeling a bit trapped in so that our clients can can benefit from you know the safety the security the growth of you know of the supervision relationship as well and I guess I'd welcome your thoughts on that um yeah so most of what I say about five minutes after I say it I reflect and think oh it's probably not that's not that's not quite right is it that's not quite true um so that's yeah i'm a chronic ruminator a chronic reflector um so when i said that about no more plateaus i did i did think well yeah there will be and there's value in the plateau with consolidation of what you know um yeah you can't consolidate if you're constantly learning um so that i guess there has to be that that kind of period where it all kind of settles
我们成长，帮助我们从不同于当前感到困顿的视角去思考如何克服困难，这样我们的客户就能从督导关系的安全感、保障和成长中受益。我想听听你对此的看法。嗯，是的，我说的很多话，在说完五分钟后，我会反思并想，哦，那可能不太对，不是吗？那不是完全正确的。所以，是的，我是一个习惯性反思者，一个习惯性思考者。所以当我那样说关于不再有平台期时，我确实想，嗯，是的，会有平台期的，而且平台期对于巩固你所学到的知识是有价值的。是的，如果你一直在学习，你就无法巩固。所以我想必须有那样一个阶段，让一切沉淀下来，
and you become confident in what you've learned and what you know. So, yeah, sure. Yeah, if we're constantly feeling like there's stuff to learn, then we're going to constantly begin to believe that we don't know anything and we're not enough so sometimes there has to be that feeling of mastery oh yeah I get this and this is what I say I've said before on the podcast is that in a cohort sometimes you will be so blown away by the experiences that people in your cohort are talking about and the the level of comfortability that they're able to
让你对自己所学和所知充满信心。所以，是的，当然。是的，如果我们一直觉得还有东西要学，那么我们就会不断开始相信自己什么都不知道，自己还不够好。所以有时必须有那种掌握感。哦，是的，我明白了。这就是我之前在播客中说过的，在一个群体中，有时你会对群体中其他人谈论的经历以及他们能够展示出的对特定主题的舒适程度感到震惊，你会觉得，哦天哪，我对那个一无所知，这会让你感到如坐针毡，让你觉得自己不够好。但实际上，在其他时候，对于某些内容，你会有非常丰富的理解和掌握感，相比于群体中的其他人。这就是临床心理学非常特别的地方，因为你们都到达了起跑线，但拥有非常不同的技能、经验和能力，我认为这非常非常特别。是的，绝对，我完全赞同每个人都知道一些你不知道的事情，这就是为什么没有人能完全独自在真空中取得任何成就。我不
demonstrate for a particular topic and you'll be like oh god I don't know anything about that and that makes you feel quite squirmy in your tummy it makes you feel not enough but actually at other times there will be stuff that you have such a rich understanding of and such a sense of mastery in comparison to perhaps what others in the cohort will have and that's what makes clinical psychology really special because you've all got to the start line but with very different skills experiences and abilities and I think that's very very special. Yeah absolutely I completely subscribe to the idea that everybody knows something you don't and that is why no one ever achieves anything completely by themselves in a vacuum i don't
认为有任何人能在没有他人投入的情况下取得成就。我曾经拥有的每一位督导、每一位客户，以及老师们，都伴随着我整个职业生涯。这不仅仅是我和我的决心，还有一路上发生的很多运气，才让我成为了现在的专业人士和现在的我。是的，我拥有的两位督导一直活在我的脑海里，绝对是这样。而且我真的很幸运，在职业生涯的两个非常不同的阶段拥有了两位非常不同的督导。所以我的第一位督导……我做助理心理学家（AP）不到两年，所以粗略地说，第一年是一位有40年经验的督导，见多识广，什么都做过，非常……我觉得
think any human has ever achieved something without any input from someone else every supervisor i've ever had every client i've ever had comes with me and teachers and stuff comes with me throughout my career and it's not just me and my determination there's a whole host of luck as well that's happened along the way that's got me to being the professional and the person that I am yeah the two supervisors I've had live rent-free in my head definitely um and I've been I've been really lucky to have two very different supervisors at two very different points in their career so my my first super so I've been I've been an AP for just just under two years um so roughly speaking the first year was with a supervisor of 40 years experience um seen it all done it all um was very um i thought
非常出色，是个很棒的人，而且非常有心理动力学的思维，所以督导过程非常开放、自由，没有议程，没有结构。我们经常谈论种花。然后我的新督导是刚获得资格的，处于入职培训阶段。所以他们向八级职级晋升的培训一部分是拥有一位受督导者。我就是那位受督导者，所以我就是那位受督导者。这是他们第一次担任临床心理学家的角色，第一次作为督导，第一次担任督导的角色。而我的第一位督导即将退休，我的新督导刚刚获得资格。虽然我不知道他们多大，但他们肯定比我年轻得多，可能比我年轻10岁左右，可能稍微
just brilliant wonderful person um and quite psychodynamic psychodynamically minded so supervision was very open free form no, no agenda, no structure. And we would often talk about growing flowers as well. And then my new supervisor was newly qualified on a preceptorship. So part of their training towards band eight was to have a supervisee. And I was that supervisee and I was that I was that supervisee so it was their first experience of being a clinical psychologist their first supervisor their first role as a supervisor and whereas my first supervisor was approaching retirement my new supervisor just qualified and although I don't know how old they are, they are definitely a lot younger than me, maybe 10-ish years younger than me, maybe a little bit
多一点。这是我们早期讨论过的事情，关于我对此的感受，记录在案，我完全没问题。我的年龄……我没有那种……我不会因为我的年龄而有任何自我意识或类似的东西。我尊重他们的角色、资格、经验水平和专业知识。但我们也讨论了他们对于拥有一位明显比自己年轻的受督导者，甚至可能想到他们在职业生涯的余下时间里可能永远不会再有比他们大10岁或以上的受督导者，他们对此有何感受。我想他们越老，这种情况就越不可能发生。你知道，当他们50岁时，他们的受督导者是60多岁的可能性就更小了。
more. And that's something that we talked about early on in terms of how I felt about that, which for the record was absolutely fine. My age doesn't i'm not like uh i don't feel any kind of ego about my age or anything like that i deferred to their role their qualification their level of experience and um expertise um but also we talked about how they felt about having a significantly younger supervisor, supervisee, and even potentially the idea that they may never have in the rest of their career a supervisee who is 10 or more years older than them. And I guess the older that they get, the less likely that will be, you know, when they're 50, it's even more unlikely that their supervisee will be in their 60s.
所以，是的，我们讨论了这一点。而且，我的意思是，我不认为这造成了任何障碍。但我认为，部分原因在于，也许我们可以从社会礼仪的角度谈谈年龄作为一种权力，因为我认为确实有几次，在学习方面存在双向关系，
So, yeah, we discussed that. And that's, I mean, it hasn't created any barriers, I don't think. But it's, I think, partly has, maybe we could talk about age as power in terms of the social graces, because there have been occasions, I think, where there's been a two-way relationship in terms of learning
甚至可能在推动特定事情方面，我作为团队的一员，觉得我们没有做这件事，而我们应该做，我是那个带头的人。但话又说回来，我现在的督导相信集体领导。所以也有空间让我这样做。这不仅仅是因为我年纪大，我觉得我更了解，因为事实并非如此。是的，我认为你绝对可以从年轻时就变得自信并成为伟大的领导者，
and maybe even driving particular things, whereby I've kind of felt as a team, we're not doing this and we should be, and I've been the one to kind of lead it. But then again, my current supervisor is a believer in kind of collective leadership. So it's also there's also been that space for me to do that. It's not just simply because I'm old and I'm like, well, I know better because that just isn't the case. Yeah, I think you absolutely can get assertive and great leaders from a young age,
但这确实是我随着年龄增长而发展起来的东西，以及我观察、停止、思考、建议和干预的自信心。而且，你知道，我不太可能容忍团队中的任何社会不公正或不平等，或者如果我认为应该发生的事情没有发生，我现在更有可能为此辩护。我认为正是我的年龄和经验使这一切成为可能。但当然，正如我所说，有些年轻人比我更快地达到了这一点。我只是意识到……对于那些不知道的人，我仍然是一名执业临床医生，所以我确实有临床病例。我只是意识到时间，因为我很快就要进行一次临床会谈。但在我们结束之前，我真的很想知道你减少职业倦怠的秘诀是什么，汤姆？
but it's something that I've developed as I've aged and my confidence for being able to just observe, stop, think and suggest and intervene. And, you know, I'm very much less likely to put up with any kind of social injustice or, you know, inequality in the team, or if I think that something's not happening that should be happening, I'm very much more likely to advocate for that now. And I think it's just my age and my experience that has allowed that to happen. But of course, like I said, there are younger people who've got there much quicker than I have.'m just conscious um for those of you don't know I am still a practicing clinician so I've got I do see a clinical caseload I'm just conscious of time because I've got a clinical session very shortly but before we finish I'd really love to know what your top tips are for reducing burnout um in in this career of ours Tom?
哦，嗯，所以我认为部分是因为我的年龄，知道时间过得很快，所以没有必要匆忙，它会发生的。这种心态帮助我一开始就不会把脚踩得太用力。同样，我认为通过年龄和经验，这是我学到的一种技能，即不要把自己的全部投入到某件事中。这并不是说我不投入到这个职业中，但我可能……你知道，可能就像十分之八，我的脚在油门上是十分之八。这是一个很糟糕的说法，但如果你明白我的意思……因为这不可持续。所以我想实际上这意味着……嗯，只是回到你刚才说的，有些日子我就是没动力。我热爱我的工作，我热爱我的
Oh um so I I think that partly because of my age and knowing that time passes quite quickly so there's no need to rush it's going to happen that kind of helps me not have my foot too hard on the pedal to begin with um and again I think through Asian experience that's that's a skill that I've learned uh to kind of not throw throw all of myself in into something so that's not to say that i don't throw myself into this career but i'm maybe you know it's maybe like eight out of ten my foot is eight out of ten on the pedal that's a really bad way of putting it but if you get my meaning um because this isn't sustainable so i guess in reality what that means is uh well just referring back to what you said earlier there are days when i just can't be bothered i love my job i love my
同事，我热爱我服务的客户。事实上，这可能是我第一次热爱我的工作，尽管如此，仍然有些日子我就是没动力。有些客户我很难真正与他们建立联系并投入工作。所以当这种情况发生时，没关系。沉浸其中，让它过去，给自己放个假。而且当该回家的时候，我就回家。周末，我不考虑我的工作，晚上也不考虑。
colleagues i love the clients that i work for um in fact it's maybe the first you know is the first time i've loved my job and that and in spite that, there are still days when I just cannot be bothered. And there are clients that I've struggled to really engage with and engage with the work. So when that happens, it's fine. Just sink into it and let it pass and just give yourself a break. And also when it's time to go home, I go home. And at the weekend, I don't think about my job and I don't think about it at night.
我想我有一个很好的工作与生活平衡。我想这是一个非常简单的说法。但在周一早上，我没有想过我们在周五督导中谈论的内容，它根本没出现在我的脑海里。有时会，这不是非黑即白的，但总的来说，我设法在周五把工作留在关闭的笔记本电脑里。很好。但我不知道这是怎么发展的，也许只是……我想是的，包容性，随着你的成长，你只是变得更擅长做
I guess I have a good work-life balance. I suppose that's a really simple way of putting it. But on the Monday morning, I haven't thought about what we talked about on Friday and supervision just hasn't crossed my mind. Sometimes it does, it's not black and white but generally speaking i i managed to to just leave it inside my shut laptop on a friday good um but i don't know how that's developed really maybe just i think yeah containment it says as you grow you just get better at doing
那件事。我认为培养和发展这种技能非常重要，并且要知道，你不去想你的客户并不代表你不关心他们，但你理应拥有自己的生活，两者是分开的。我当时在想，我喜欢关于油门到底的类比。你知道，当你开车时，或者即使你走过一个把油门踩到底的人身边，这很令人痛苦。这很不方便。你知道，这会让你觉得，哦，这太累人了。所以虽然你可能认为你需要一直不停地奋斗，但在团队中如果有人这样做，真的不太好。你知道，我职业生涯中也绝对有过不停奋斗的时候，那可能很难相处，因为我会说，这个服务需要缩短等待名单，我会向你展示我们正在做，
that I think and it's really important to develop and cultivate as a skill and to know that you don't not care about your clients because you're not thinking about them but you deserve to have your life and the two are separate and I was thinking I love the analogy about the pedal to the metal you know when you are driving with or even if you're walking past somebody that is doing 10 out of 10 pedal to the metal, it's distressing. It's inconvenient. You know, it makes you go, oh, it's exhausting. And so whilst you might think you need to be relentless all the time, it's really not nice in a team if someone is doing that you know and I've absolutely been relentless at points in my career that have probably been quite hard to be around because I'm like this service needs a shorter wait list and I'm going to show you that we're doing it
我们正在做，我们正在做，因为这些客户值得更好的服务。我相信这对我的同事来说有时很困难，因为我会说，对我来说生产力就是问责制，50%面对面，你知道，我能做到，我们都能做到，让我们完成它，让我们让这些客户有更好的体验。但如果你一直这样做，你不会很受欢迎，你会精疲力竭，你知道，最终你对你如此渴望支持的服务或客户没有任何用处。是的，绝对。我想为了完成这个类比，你使用的转速越高，消耗的汽油就越多。哦，确实如此。说到这里，汤姆，真的很抱歉，我得走了。
we're doing it we're doing it because these clients deserve a better service and I'm sure that was difficult for my colleagues at times because I was like productivity to me it's accountability 50 face-to-face you know i can do it we can all do it let's get it done let's get these clients have a better experience but if you do that all the time you're not going to be very well liked and you're going to burn out and you know ultimately you're not going to be any use to the service or the clients that you so badly want to support yeah absolutely i suppose to complete the analogy you, the more revs you use, the more petrol you burn. Oh, you certainly do. And on that note, Tom, I'm really sorry, I'm going to have to go.
但和你交谈真是最大的荣幸，祝愿你在接下来的三年及以后一切顺利。如果你想在任何阶段回到播客，随时告诉我。而且，你知道，如果你需要任何包容或建议，我在这里支持你。在任何阶段回到播客，随时告诉我，你知道，如果你需要任何包容或建议，我在这里支持你。嗯，随时欢迎进入我的私信。谢谢。嗯，谢谢你邀请我，玛丽安。能来这里随机聊天真是我的荣幸。嗯，谢谢每一位收听的人，希望它不乏味。它一点也不乏味。它充满活力，像焦橙色一样。愿你的甜菜根茁壮成长。是的，正是如此。这是一个多么好的结束语。非常感谢。乔什，和托马斯交谈真是太荣幸了。我真的
But it's been the biggest pleasure speaking with you and wishing you so well for these next three years and beyond. And if you want to come back on the podcast at any stage, give me a shout. And, you know, I'm here for you if you need any containment or advice the podcast at any stage give me a shout and you know i'm here for you if you need any containment or advice um feel free to slip into my dms thanks um thanks for having me marianne it's been um a privilege to come on and and just just chat randomly and um thank you to uh everyone who's listened i hope it wasn't bland. It was not bland. It was vibrant and burnt orange. And may your beetroots flourish. Yes, exactly. What a great note to finish on. Thank you so much. Josh, what an absolute pleasure to speak with Thomas. And I really
祝愿他在接下来的几个月和几年里一切顺利。你会很高兴知道我确实准时参加了我的客户会谈。但是的，我确实是一名执业临床医生。我负责临床病例，同时也为你们这些有抱负的心理学家社区做所有这些零碎的事情。如果你想更深入地了解我的世界，请查看“有抱负的心理学家会员”的详细信息，你可以在节目说明、描述或我任何社交渠道的个人简介链接中找到。我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。来找我。来关注我。来和我联系。
wish him all the best with these next coming months and years. You'll be pleased to know I did make my client session on time. But yeah, I really am a practicing clinician. I hold a clinical caseload, as well as running all of these bits and pieces for you guys in the aspiring psychologist community. And if you would like to come closer into my world, do check out the details for the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can find in the show notes or in the description or in the bio link of any of my social channels. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. Come and find me. Come and follow me. Come and connect with me.
并让我知道你真正看重什么内容。我期待着为你提供这些。来和我联系，让我知道你真正看重什么内容，我期待着为你提供这些。别忘了，我们有即将到来的申请季的同情问答日期，第一个是在2023年9月4日星期一晚上6点，第二个是2023年10月3日星期二晚上6点。第三个是2023年11月7日星期二晚上6点。它们都可以通过我的社交渠道免费流媒体播放，也可以在重播中观看。观看重播的最佳地点是玛丽安·特伦特博士的YouTube频道。来那里关注我，来订阅，你也可以查看我之前的播放列表。总之，非常感谢你收听或观看这一集，
And let me know what content it is that you would really value. And I will look forward to offering that to you. come and connect with me and let me know what content it is that you would really value and I will look forward to offering that to you don't forget we've got compassionate Q&A dates coming up for the application season the first of those is on Monday the 4th of September 2023 at 6 p.m the second of those is Tuesday the 3rd of October 2023 at 6 p. The third is Tuesday the 7th of November 2023 at 6pm. They're all available for free streamed via my social channels and will be available on replay as well. The best place to catch the replay is on Dr Marianne Trent YouTube. Come and follow me there, come and subscribe and you can also check out my previous playlist there too. Anyway, thank you so much for listening to this episode or watching it,
取决于你在做什么。我期待着在下次聚会时为你提供更多精彩内容，时间是下周一早上6点，届时将播出下一集《有抱负的心理学家播客》。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请善待自己。保重。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那么让这成为你的指南，有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，由玛丽安·特伦特博士主持。没有记忆入口。我的名字是贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
depending on what you are doing. And I will look forward to providing more great content for you when we next get together, which will be from 6am on Monday for the next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. Thank you so much for being part of my world and do be kind to yourself. Take care. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast With Dr. Marianne Trent Without the memory entrance My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径可以达到目标，没有成为心理学家的完美方式。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.